let's bring in louisiana senator john
kennedy he's joining us from louisiana
on this monday senator good morning
good morning well you look at what's
going on on our southern border you know
back
in march joe biden when he was trying to
explain why so many people were surging
in january february and march he said
you know that's just what happens during
the winter months when it's cooler
we have so many people coming through
and now we're in the summer months
and we've got much much bigger numbers
of people coming through so
obviously the president's logic
on cooler weather hotter weather not
completely accurate
well i think that's true and i don't
think
the binding administration has ever told
the truth about the border i
i read the article about president biden
biden's decision to pay the contractors
two billion
dollars not to build the wall
not to finish the wall and here's my
conclusion
about that what do you call
a genius in president biden's homeland
security department a visitor
what he what he's doing is a crime
against nature and
intelligence for two reasons number one
it's an obscene waste of taxpayer money
senate republicans are scrambling right
now to
to pass an infrastructure bill that's
paid for
we could use this two billion dollars
that he is wasting that would overlay
about
1 600 miles of of four lane highways
number two
border walls in terms of border security
or a fat guy layup there's a reason
that saudi arabia has a 500-mile border
wall with iraq
there's a reason that israel has a
400-mile border wall
um
in its country there's a reason that
there's a border wall between north and
south korea there's a reason that france
has a border wall in bulgaria and
morocco
border walls work and we've had
a border wall for 30 years in america
every president since then has supported
it including
president obama and president clinton
except president
biden i think the conclusion is almost
inescapable folks that president biden
believes in open borders yeah he voted
for it when in 2006
there's no doubt about it would help so
now we've paid this money now we're
going to spend two billion dollars
to store or destroy a wall that we need
it's all vindictiveness because he
doesn't like president trump
and i think it's it's it's the
anti-leadership
it's everything you don't want in a
president
well i think it's also an indication
that
let's be honest president biden didn't
tell the american people the truth
when he was running he believes in open
borders he believes the board is a
nuisance
he believes that vetting people at the
border is racist
he thinks anybody he ought to be able to
come into america
since president biden has been in office
a million people
have come into america from the southern
border
and ground the slightest i do idea who
they are all right
we know who you are senator kennedy
thank you very much for joining us today
thank you all right